[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a esta entrevista en
francés 24 y radio Francia internacional
nuestro invitado Hoy es el presidente de
la república de Colombia Gustavo Petro
Muchas gracias señor presidente gracias
bien gracias y conmigo para esta
entrevista Angélica Pérez de radio
Francia internacional Gracias Marta
presidente quiero hablar de la guerra
entre Ucrania y Rusia Lula hace poco
dijo que el presidente de Ucrania
golovdimir selenski eran tan responsable
como el mandatario ruso Vladimir Putin
es su opinión
yo voy un poquito más allá
América Latina ha sido invadida muchas
veces lo primero invasión España y
Portugal
pero de ahí en adelante Me siguieron los
franceses invadieron los ingleses
invadieron los norteamericanos y las
invasiones norteamericanas han sido
bastantes ya la historia reciente
hemos visto invasiones en el medio
oriente en El Siglo 21
Irak Libia Siria porque hay unas
invasiones que son buenas y se aplauden
y los mismos que aplauden esas
invasiones rechazan otras
Hay invasiones buenas y si hay
invasiones malas
o hay un eje de interés en el poder que
Determine y califica unas u otras
promueve unas y ataca a otras
dependiendo de su propio interés
geopolítico y en esa medida nuestras
nuestros activistas cuando en la se
discutía el tratado internacional de
Roma de la Corte Penal Internacional
desde la sociedad civil no estábamos en
el gobierno
propusieron algo que me parece
absolutamente pertinente para hoy si
vamos a rechazar una invasión que yo la
rechazo
rechacemos todas
las pasadas y las futuras y elevemos a
delito internacional a crimen
internacional
la agresión
toda agresión internacional
independientemente de quién la haga
sobre quién la haga debe ser considerado
un delito internacional jugable en sus
responsables personalizados pero el
responsable es más Vladimir Putin Que es
que en este caso es una discusión que se
la dejó a usted
porque
nosotros observamos o es Estados Unidos
no observamos un juego tan
que fue propiciando la construcción de
una reacción rusa
y la reacción rusa se dio sobre un
pueblo que no tenía nada que ver ni con
la otan Ni color rusos que es el pueblo
ucraniano ese juego que también se quiso
imponer en la esquina
suramericana A la que pertenezco otan
rusos la lucha comercial Estados Unidos
china no representa los intereses de
América Latina
y en esa medida lo mejor que podemos
hacer nosotros es tomar distancia
y proponer La Paz Si Lula quiere firmar
con nosotros con el presidente mexicano
y con otros gobiernos del mundo una
exhortación al diálogo inmediato a La
tregua inmediata y a finalizar la guerra
de inmediato nosotros estamos dispuestos
a firmarlo usted ha cuestionado en la
otan acaba de mencionarla presidente de
Colombia Colombia es el único país que
tiene un acuerdo global desde 2018 con
la alianza del Atlántico Norte un
acuerdo que le permite tener una
estrecha cooperación con la otan en
cuestiones militares cuestiones de
seguridad los militares colombianos el
ejército colombiano está dando formación
a pedido de la otan a los soldados
ucranianos en desminado
considera usted pertinente continuar con
este acuerdo global con la otan que
diversos sectores no son en Colombia
sino latinoamericanos lo consideraron en
su momento como la puerta abierta en
intervención ismo el guer en la región
la otra significa Alianza Atlántico
Norte Nosotros somos del Caribe y el
Pacífico y muy pronto y muy pero muy
latinoamericanos pidió a usted en 2013
la palabra latinoamericanos un poco
pequeña
porque somos más que latinos
los latinos la herencia latina lo hace
parte pero no solo ella sino también la
afro los indígenas ancestrales que
estaban antes de los romanos
los árabes que hicieron parte de las
embarcaciones de la conquista traídos a
la fuerza por los españoles etcétera
ha generado una diversidad tan grande
que latinoamericano no expresa
exactamente lo que somos pero
digamos aceptando el término y sin
discutirlo el el yo prefiero una alianza
latinoamericana
es un camino que hay que construir
obviamente pero
en la perspectiva de la geopolítica
mundial Y estos conflictos que no nos
representan
que no tienen que ver con fórmulas
sociales diferentes tiene que ver es con
poderes económicos que se enfrentan con
incapacidades por ejemplo la de Europa
occidental para pasar a las energías
limpias que la hizo depender del gas y
al depender del gas ha provocado el
conflicto la incapacidad ha provocado el
conflicto
nosotros deberíamos juntarnos no
solamente en una perspectiva económica
no solamente en la perspectiva futura de
lo que significa la crisis climática
para América Latina y como
planificamos y nos organizamos alrededor
de de ese objetivo de superar la crisis
climática con una agenda de
carbonización sino también desde el
punto de vista militar
que nunca seremos ofensivos
ningún país latinoamericano Que yo
recuerde ha sido ofensivo siempre hemos
sido defensivos
y yo creo que eso es importante porque
en la gran Constitución de nuestros
pueblos siempre tiene que estar escrita
como una prioridad la paz del mundo
ya se ha hablado con los otros países ha
habido ciertas intenciones pero hasta
ahora eso no tiene una realidad hablando
de paz el 4 de noviembre usted sancionó
la ley con la cual se pone en marcha el
proceso dicho de paz total entre otros
Eso significa negociaciones con la guía
del Ln las disidencias de las FARC y
también grupos armados de manera muy
concreta hay Resultados ya hay
negociaciones qué está pasando nosotros
recogimos el estado en que quedó el
proceso de paz de Santos
Ahora hay que cumplirlo ese acuerdo vale
bastante dinero el primer punto No más
que es el que me ha acertado en estos
meses que es la reforma agraria sobre
tres millones de hectáreas de tierra
fértil
ese Solo punto vale entre 30 y 60
billones más o menos entre 6000 y 8 mil
millones de dólares
en un lapso corto de tiempo que hay que
conseguir y que tenemos nosotros que
poner
en una inversión porque no es realmente
un gasto esas tres millones de hectáreas
empezarían a producir alimentos
generarían unos multiplicadores
económicos
aparecería una clase media rural Pero
bueno digamos ese es un punto cumplir
los acuerdos de paz con las que abre
las opciones digamos de paz con el Ln
que también
estaban en un punto intermedio
interrumpido brutalmente yo de ese punto
intermedio he partido reconocido los
protocolos etcétera
dónde estamos ahora Estamos en que el Ln
de acuerdo a la ley que se acaba de
aprobar ya ha elegido han escogido unos
voceros negociadores de la organización
tiene diferentes denominaciones
Nosotros hemos hecho lo mismo ya se hará
público en su momento en este instante
no se puede no se ha escogido el lugar
será lo que viene un punto
había sido Cuba
y porque Cuba prestó su territorio la
derecha extrema que gobernó el país
después del gobierno de Santos decidió
insinuarle o más bien decirle a la
extrema derecha que gobernó Estados
Unidos después del acuerdo de paz que
colocará Cuba en los países terroristas
y lo hicieron decir el castigo a Cuba
por haber ofrecido su territorio para
hacer la paz en Colombia fue haberlo
conducido a un aislamiento internacional
más profundo a través de la lista de
países que favorecen el terrorismo ese
punto geográfico y entonces es más
problemático porque está ese antecedente
y estamos en eso en el lugar donde se
van a hacer las negociaciones
una vez negociadores de un lado
negociadores del otro se sienten en ese
punto geográfico con una unos países que
se han ofrecido para ser garantes del
proceso entre esos Cuba Noruega y
Venezuela
estaba Brasil ya habrá que ver qué pasa
después de diciembre con Brasil hay
países que se han acercado al proceso
Francia acaba de decirme que cuente con
el gobierno francés en todo España se
acercó Incluso en reunión conmigo en el
período de campaña
España llevó al Ln a la lista de
terroristas en Europa y genera cierto
ruido pero en general el mundo ha
expresado
es su apoyo al inicio de un proceso de
paz con el Ln pero nosotros no nos
queremos quedar ahí solamente queremos
recuperar para la paz las disidencias
hoy armadas de las FARC
y queremos abrir una perspectiva
cuyo hilo es difícil de establecer su la
frontera porque las condiciones de la
del conflicto y la violencia en Colombia
sean permeado del narcotráfico desde
hace mucho tiempo la diferenciación está
más en los orígenes que en la actualidad
Pero hay organizaciones puramente
narcotraficantes que tienen control
territorial que se han empoderado sobre
todo en los últimos años casi que
necesitaríamos todo el abecedario para
denominarlas y con ellas también
queremos establecer
no tanto un diálogo político porque un
diálogo político Versa sobre el poder
y no se trata de conceder poder al
narcotráfico sino es un diálogo jurídico
en donde el poder judicial puede
negociar con este tipo de organizaciones
beneficios jurídicos a cambio de un auto
desmantelación
desmantelamiento Pacífico de sí mismas
bajo los principios de verdad justicia y
reparación en cierta forma es quitar el
proletariado del narcotráfico
el narcotráfico quizás siga Porque
mientras haya prohibición de la cocaína
habrá mafia
y con un paso adelante en por lo menos
desde la perspectiva de la pacificación
de Colombia y con Iván Márquez el ex
jefe de FARC hay discusiones hay canales
abiertos con él de manera muy concreta
Iván Márquez es una de las disidencias
Pero hay contactos que hace poco supimos
que estaba vivo
porque el gobierno oficialmente lo había
dado por muerto como muchos otros que
han aparecido vivos y que pues no
sabíamos pero el
todo el conjunto de incidencias queremos
que se acoja un proceso de paz Colombia
Usted lo sabe claro el mayor productor
de cocaína en el mundo y víctima de eso
mismo usted como presidente colombiano
denuncia el fracaso total de la política
antidrogas por por prohibicionista por
ecocida Y esa guerra contra las drogas
ilícitas estas ha sido determinada
diseñada desde hace 50 años por Estados
Unidos
está encontrado altos funcionarios del
gobierno estadounidense el secretario de
estado blinquen una delegación oficial
que envió su padre Joe biden a hablar
expresamente con ustedes el jefe de la
Cia qué respuestas concretas da
Washington medidas concretas a Esa
visión que tiene usted de lo que debe
ser realmente la lucha contra el
narcotráfico y el manejo de las drogas
ilícitas y la otra es la hoja de Coca el
sector político que hoy gobierna Estados
Unidos
es consciente de que fracasó la guerra
contra las drogas
en su sociedad no lo pueden digamos
donde tienen que mover muy prudentemente
muy paquidermicamente pero creo que son
conscientes es lo que hemos hablado
hay digamos las cifras son contundentes
es que hay un millón de Muertos
latinoamericanos
es que millones de personas la mayoría
negras han pasado por consumir o portar
una pequeña cantidad en las cárceles de
Estados Unidos
es que las mafias son más poderosas que
antaño el famoso Pablo Escobar que
palidece ante el poder hoy de
organizaciones que pueden organizarte un
ejército al mismo estilo de los Marines
controlando territorios en cualquier
parte de América que pueden poner
estados arrodillados como Haití que
pueden
digamos desestabilizar a tal punto la
democracia que han convertido América en
unos lugares más violentos señor
presidente usted quiere la legalidad
acción
en Colombia y también otra pregunta muy
concreta usted quiere parar extradición
de narcotráfico antes a Estados Unidos
en primer lugar la legalización en
Colombia de la cocaína no sirve para
nada
nos bloquearían los aislaríamos del
mundo
sería incluso mucho más violento el
fenómeno
en segundo lugar lo que proponemos no es
un liberalismo alrededor del consumo de
las drogas y algunas sociedades pues
permiten
sino lo que proponemos es que todo el
dinero destinado a una guerra fracasada
que son muchos miles de millones de
dólares se dedica a prevenir el consumo
de tal manera que con la cocaína pase lo
mismo que ha pasado con la nicotina
hay sociedades que aún fuman la nuestra
ya no
en Colombia se puede demostrar que sin
criminalizar el consumo de tabaco o
cigarrillos nicotina en general
con la campaña de prevención y con los
cambios que la sociedad va teniendo en
el tiempo se redujo casi a cero ese
consumo
no es fácil encontrar a alguien que en
Colombia porque se puede hacer eso
siendo legal el consumo de cigarrillo
y no se puede hacer con la boca
si la sociedad es cambian en el tiempo
son más afectuosas menos competitivas
entre sí
si se hace esa inversión de miles de
millones de dólares en prevenir en
educar tenga usted la seguridad que el
consumo de cocaína tenderá a 0 en el
tiempo
Y eso eso es lo que se trata Y no habrá
muertos
no ahora este desastre en que se ha
conducido América Latina en estos 50
años
la perspectiva serían diferentes
Entonces digamos no hablo de
discriminalizar simplemente para que
entonces la cocaína se convierta en una
especie de
coca-cola en Consumo en todo el mundo no
hablo es de
redireccionar la lucha antidrogas de tal
manera que abandones sus aspectos
militares violentos y represivos y aún
de los aspectos de la salud pública y de
la prevención porque creo que es el
camino más eficaz
Durante los últimos años el presidente
de Venezuela Nicolás Maduro ha sido
considerado como persona no grata en la
escena internacional hoy la emergencia
climática nos emplaza a salvar la selva
amazónica Usted lo ha propuesto y
Venezuela tiene que hacer parte de
importante de esta Cruzada mundial para
salvar la amazonía así lo ha formulado
usted en la copa 27 yo te pregunto el
señor presidente usted está dándole la
mano a su homólogo venezolano para que
retorne a la escena internacional como
presidente legítimo en una
revitalización No solamente la selva
amazónica sino tal vez de la selva de
relaciones diplomáticas internacionales
Pues sí pero también no solamente a
escenarios como la cobre etcétera sino
también a las reuniones en México
ahora
una vez termine este programa voy hacia
una mesa que se instala para hablar del
tema con el gobierno francés argentino
con delegado de la oposición y el
gobierno venezolano porque se trata de
construir un camino
efectivo que permita que las elecciones
del 2024 sean un pacto social en
Venezuela
habrá elecciones en el 2024 Pero estas
no deben ser como las anteriores en el
camino de una polarización y los
venezolanos no llegan a la violencia
colombiana pero podría ese camino llevar
hacia violencias armadas e incluso sino
un camino de pacto fíjese usted que si
uno mira el tema selva amazónica crisis
climáticas etcétera En Venezuela poco se
ha discutido
Qué puede significar para un país que
desde hace un siglo casi Desde los
primeros
tiempos del petróleo vive del petróleo
que ha sido rico Dependiendo el precio
internacional y pobres y el precio
internacional se ha desplomado
el bloqueo
ha provocado alguna discusión en
Venezuela ahora sobre cómo puede
Venezuela vivir sin petróleo
pero creo que la discusión de la crisis
climática lo pondría sobre la mesa y a
mí hasta me interesaría mucho que en
esos acuerdos que tienen más con las
medidas represivas que se han tomado las
que podrían tomar si la contraparte
ganas sobre las garantías de las
elecciones para el 2024 para ambas
partes se pusiera también en discusión
para las fuerzas políticas venezolanas
que va a ser Venezuela cuando las
demandas de petróleo se desplomen en los
próximos años o décadas por precisamente
para salvar la humanidad de la crisis
climática cual la transición Por qué
caminos
se puede
transitar hacia una economía productiva
esa sería una agenda de un verdadero
acuerdo político y un verdadero pacto
social obviamente yo no estoy allá no
puedo presionarlo lo que me interesa es
que Venezuela esté en paz Sí porque
Colombia puede estar en pasta Sí pero
señor presidente para muchos Nicolás
Maduro no es el verdadero presidente de
Venezuela porque hubo esta elección está
sospechado de crímenes de lesa humanidad
por las Naciones Unidas y lo que ustedes
está haciendo es legitimar a alguien que
no lo merece Cuál es su respuesta esas
son posiciones políticas Naciones Unidas
reconoce a maduro
las violaciones de Derechos Humanos
que yo sí creo que han sucedido en
Venezuela
han subido peor en Colombia
y lo que he visto es abrazarse con los
presidentes de Colombia
cuando han muerto miles de jóvenes
fusilados por el ejército
cuando en la última manifestación de
jóvenes mataron 100
y tienen 200 presos
Y eso que es
propuesto a Venezuela como le he
propuesto a Colombia y como le propongo
América Latina el que volvamos a
fortalecer el la convención americana
como el gran tratado de derechos humanos
de la región desde Alaska hasta la
Patagonia yo soy presidente porque me
tocó
acudir a la Corte Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos para salvar mis
derechos políticos de lo contrario
de por vida me los habían quitado en
Colombia y hasta puedo decir que por
suerte porque estoy vivo Porque si
hubiera sido hace unos años atrás el
candidato presidencial de la izquierda
hubiera sido asesinado
es que en este tema de Derechos Humanos
hay que hablar con autoridad moral
y resulta que muchos que critican a
otros tienen un peor problema en su
propio país yo invité a Venezuela a
ingresar al sistema interamericano es
decir qué significa eso invité a
Venezuela a aceptar una carta de
derechos para todas sus y su su
ciudadanía
que en el pasado
individuos concretos violaron derechos
humanos o cometieron crimes crímenes que
se pueden calificar del orden
internacional Pues para eso son las
investigaciones
nosotros queremos que en Colombia
también se investiguen y que en toda
América se investiguen que nadie tiene
por qué ser al ser gobernante tener la
capacidad o la impunidad de violar los
Derechos Humanos pero partamos de un
principio de lo que se trata no es de
condenar a los países para que siempre
se quiebren los Derechos Humanos sino
para que salgan de ese tipo de episodios
a partir de
un acuerdo político de un pacto se
cumplen 100 días de su gobierno el
primero de izquierda en Colombia que
llega con una ambiciosa agenda social
que la llaman en La Paz total ustedes
esas grandes transformaciones presidente
implica tocar intereses teme usted que
sectores
cuyos que se vean afectados económica o
ideológicamente puedan intentar
desestabilizar su gobierno o
desestabilizar lo voy a tentar contra él
están
no me acabe de posicionar y ya se
citaban manifestaciones pensaban que
iban a ser muy grandes hasta los han
sido muy muy muy pequeñas
han pensado ver cómo rompen la coalición
mayoritaria que logré conformar en el
congreso hasta ahora no han podido
a diario la actividad en prensa
colombiana
de desinformación
acaba de salir como dos o tres encuestas
no he podido verlas bien de los mismos
medios de comunicación y dan 61 60% de
favorabilidad al gobierno y dicen que sí
pero la mayoría de los colombianos Están
en contra de sus políticas Entonces
porque ahí tenemos un 61% de
favorabilidad digamos hasta este momento
pero ha pasado muy poco tiempo tres
meses
Sí hemos sentido la intención la acción
Pero ha sido muy débil porque hasta este
momento
la fortaleza del gobierno es alta en la
sociedad en la política la construcción
de ese frente que permitió ganar se
mantiene sólida hemos logrado es atraer
sectores que votaron contra nosotros
sectores de la sociedad millones de
colombianos que votaron contra nosotros
hoy nosotros no digo que eso se va a
mantener en el tiempo pero hasta el
momento eso nos ha permitido ser fuertes
en el país gracias señor presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro y gracias a
ustedes por su compañía a los oyentes de
radio Francia internacional y a los
espectadores de Francia 24
[Música]